>>> WE'RE BACK WITH COVERAGE
FROM THE HEARING AND THE DAMNING
PORTRAIT PAINTED BY CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH BOB AND CARL
WHO'S REPORTING UNCOVERED THE
WATERGATE SCANDAL.
WOODWARD IS ALSO THE CO-AUTHOR
OF THE BOOK, PERIL, ABOUT THE
LAST DAYS OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY AND BERNSTEIN IS THE
AUTHOR OF CHASING HISTORY, A KID
IN THE NEWS ROOM.
BOTH EXCELLENT, EXCELLENT BOOKS
AND THANKS TO CARL AND BOB FOR
JOIN US.
CARL, WE'VE SPOKEN THROUGHOUT
THESE HEARINGS.
YOU AND I HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER
FOR MANY YEARS AND YOU'VE
SUGGESTED TO ME MANY TIMES THAT
THIS, WHAT HAS HAPPENED DURING
THE INSURRECTION, IS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
DID WE LEARN TODAY JUST HOW MUCH
WORSE IT WAS?
>> WE DID.
AND SOMETHING ELSE HAS OCCURRED
TO ME AND THAT IS, WE'LL SEE
WHAT THE HISTORIANS SAY, BUT IF
SHE IS NOT CONTRADICTED, SHE HAS
NAILED THE GREATEST CONSPIRACY,
CRIMINAL AND SEDITIOUS, AGAINST
THE REPUBLIC OF THE SINCE THE
CIVIL WAR AND JEFFERSON DAVIS.
HE WAS A MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
NOT THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
NO PRESIDENT HAS ENGAGED,
INCLUDING NIXON, HAS ENGAGED IN
ANYTHING LIKE WE HEARD TODAY SO
IF WHAT SHE IS SAYING IS
ACCURATE, NOW WE SEE THE SECRET
SERVICE IS SAYING THEY'RE
COOPERATING.
I'D BE VERY SURPRISED IF THEY
CONTRADICT HER.
THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
SHE PAINTED, YOU JUST IN YOUR
INTRODUCTION, TALKING ABOUT THE
PICTURE SHE PAINTED.
SHE PICTURED A MAN -- THE
STABILITY, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WHICH
INCIDENTALLY, REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN IN THE SENATE AND SOME IN
THE HOUSE, QUESTIONING HIS
STABILITY SINCE THE FIRST DAYS
OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
THEY'VE TOLD REPORTERS ABOUT IT.
WE'VE REPORTED IT OCCASIONALLY.
WE SHOULD HAVE REPORTED IT MUCH
MORE AND FOUND A WAY TO DO IT
BETTER BECAUSE WE HAVE KNOWN,
I'VE PUT IT ON THE AIR, OTHERS
HAVE, WE HAVEN'T BEEN CONSISTENT
ABOUT IT.
WE'VE KNOWN THIS IS AN UNSTABLE
MAN.
THE 25th AMENDMENT.
THERE WERE MEMBERS OF THE
CABINET WHO WANTED TO INVOKE IT
INCLUDING THE WIFE OF SENATOR
McCONNELL.
THE MAJORITY OR THE LEADER OF
THE REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE.
SHE QUIT THE NEXT DAY.
AFTER JANUARY 6th.
BETSY DEVOS.
THE SECRETARY OF EDUCATION.
QUIT THE NEXT DAY.
WHY?
THEY UNDERSTOOD WHAT THIS
PRESIDENT WAS CAPABLE OF IN THIS
TERRIBLE, HORRIBLE SEDITIOUS
WAY.
>> LET ME GET BOB TO WEIGH IN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
HOW MUCH WORSE IS THIS THAN
WATERGATE?
>> WELL, THE PORTRAIT HERE OF
MENTAL NSTABILITY AND I THINK
IT GOES FURTHER.
GENERAL MILLIE, CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS, WORRYING ABOUT THE
MENTAL STABILITY OF THE
PRESIDENT, HE GETS THIS CALL
FROM NANCY PELOSI, THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, SAYING WE'RE, THAT
SHE, THAT YOU KNOW, THE NEXT IN
LINE AFTER THE VICE PRESIDENT TO
BE PRESIDENT IF SOMETHING
HAPPENS AND SHE KNOWS ALL ABOUT
THIS AND THE PROTOCOLS AND SHE
SAYS TRUMP IS CRAZY.
HE'LL START USING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
HOW CAN YOU, THE NUMBER ONE
MILITARY MAN IN THE COUNTRY
GUARANTEE ME THIS WILL NOT
HAPPEN?
AND HE SAID, OH, EVERYTHING'S
FINE, DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
THEN HE STARTS THINKING ABOUT IT
AND DEVELOPED THIS PHRASE.
THE ABSOLUTE DARKEST MOMENT OF
THEORETICAL POSSIBILITY IS IN
HIS JOB, HE HAD TO LOOK AT THE
ABSOLUTE WORST HAPPENING AND HE
THEN RECONSIDERED AND WAS SO
WORRIED, CALLED IN THE OFFICERS
IN THE PENTAGON WHO RUN THE
NATIONAL MILITARY COMMAND CENTER
AND TAKE ORDERS FROM THE
NATIONAL COMMAND AUTHORITY,
WHICH IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO USE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS OR TO LAUNCH SOME SORT
OF MILITARY ACTION AND MILLIE
CALLED THESE PEOPLE IN.
ONE STAR OFFICERS, COLONELS,
CAPTAINS IN THE NAVY, AND WENT
AROUND THE ROOM AND SAID, DO YOU
UNDERSTAND?
I HAVE TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS.
I WANT YOUR PERSONAL OATH AND
GUARANTEE THAT IF THAT HAPPENS,
YOU WILL CALL ME.
HAS PHONES ALL OVER CORRIDOR SIX
WHERE HE LIVES AND THEY SAID,
YES, YES, YES.
NOW, FOR THIS HAPPENED IN
WATERGATE.
CARL AND I REMEMBER THIS VIVIDLY
WHEN THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
SLESSINGER TOLD THE MILITARY,
DON'T TAKE ORDERS FROM NIXON
ABOUT NUCLEAR WEAPONS OR ANY
MILITARY ACTION.
SO WE WOULD, I THINK IN A WAY
WHAT HAPPENED TODAY MAY MEAN
THAT THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
HAS WRITTEN DONALD TRUMP'S
POLITICAL OBITUARY.
>> REALLY.
>> YES.
I THINK IT'S THAT DEVASTATING.
CARL AND I SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WITH REPUBLICANS AND REPUBLICANS
DON'T WANT SOMEBODY WHO, I MEAN,
THE PORTRAIT THAT WAS PAINTED
TODAY OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES LEAPING FROM THE
BACKSEAT TRYING TO GRAB THE
STEERING WHEEL --
>> AND ALLEGEDLY CHOKING HIS TOP
SECRET SERVICE AGENT.
I MEAN, PRETTY DRAMATIC.